3年前のあの日のことは
今でも忘れられない
2016年
1月22日
私の祖父は心停止しました
現場に居合わせた遊ぶは
祖父の突然の新弟子に何も手を施すことができませんでした
新弟子に効果的である aed を使うにも ad の場所も蘇生いつもわからなかっ
たそうです
幸い祖父は一命を取り留めましたが
当時医療従事者を目指していた私は
駆けつけた病院ですぎゅっと祖父の手を握りしめることしかできませんでした
医療に興味を持ちながらも祖父に対して何もできなかった自分が悔しくて仕方がなかっ
た
その時以来いい将来誰かの命を救うのではなくて今の自分に何ができるかを考えるよう
になり
そして私は心停止や救命に関することの調査を始めました
そこで私は衝撃の現実を目の当たりにしました
7.5分に1人
心臓突然死デー
日本人が命を落としている
しかしこの新弟子を減らすために効果的なのが aed です
tt の正式名称は自動体外式除細動器
具体的には正常に動いていない心臓に電気ショックを与えて心臓を正常な状態に戻す
装置です
この ad は日本に60万台もあります
しかしこのうち aed を使って救われた命は
たったの600人なんです
なぜ aed は使われていないのでしょうか
現状の救命システムはこうです新弟子が起こった場合発見者は119番通報します
そしてその後に必要だと分かった場合 ad を取りにいて
救助現場へ戻ってきますでも皆さんよく考えてみてください
今目の前で人が倒れましたその時皆さんは ad 思って3分から5分以内に今ここに
ad を持って来れますか
持ってくるのは難しいと思いますでも今日この会場に入るとき
自動ドアの所に ad のマークあった人にあったあったことに気づいた人は何にいた
でしょうか
実際エレベーターに横にある事務室に aed があります
でも aed があっても皆さん気付かないんです
エーゲが必要なとき ad の場所がわからないんです
じゃあ救急車を的そう思っても救急車平均到着時間はなんと8点5分
救急車を待ってみてもこのグラフの通り
人の命は救えません
そこで a 員の融合活用されていない原因は私は2つを考えました
一つ目は aed の場所がわからないこと
そして2つ目は今いる場所から aed そしてまた age をとって戻ってくると
いう多くかかることで時間がかかると考えました
そこで私が考えたのが
aed の場所が分からなくても aed が素早く救助現場へ届く
aed 愛です
adi というのは aed にただタブレット端末をつけただけです
このタブレット端末が何をするかというと
aed のところにいた人がこのタブレットを持って ad の場所から倒れた現場
までの地図裕度をこのタブレットを行いますそうすることで倒れた現場にいたいとの
付近の人は営利を探さなくて済む
そして ad
から救助現場へ行って来るため片道ですみます
そうすることで ad の救命気によって救命率が向上すると私は考えています
具体的な使い方の動画がこちらです
にしかさんしかさん皆さん
おい皆さん
[音楽]
格子点発見者が消防署に今いる場所を伝えます
ん
証拠です感じですかピンキーですか
[音楽]
近くの駅に件バイト情報を終えました
こうして消防署から食べれぷ端末に位置情報を送信して ad 付近にいる人がこの
食べる営利愛を手に取ります
そしてタブレットにしづ誘導をもとに adi を運搬します
具体的にタブレットにはこのように今いる aed の場所から倒れた現場までの地図
裕度を行います
思っ
そして aed が adi が救助現場椅子は素早く届きます
しかし ad はこれだけではないありません
adi が救助現場へ届いた時このタブレット端末には aed の使用方法の動画を
流します
こうすることで
ad が運ばれてきた場合確実に a 気を使うことができるようになります
さらに私は高校時代この adi の効果検証を行うために地元の企業や行政と連携し
ました
私は企画書をつくって一人で市役所や
消防車に電話をかけまた企業のお問い合わせのホームページから協力を依頼しました
そして実際行政や企業両方ともすごく協力をしてくれて
実際本当に特別に119の回線を使って実験も行うことができました
その結果従来 ad と事務次官が8分24秒と言われていたのが ad 平均当時9
時間が2分31秒まで縮まることに成功しました
そしてこの adi のアイディアや窓この行動力が評価されて私は高校時代に
全国高校生マイプロジェクトアワードという全国の高校生が集まってアイディアを発表
する全国大会で日本一の文部科学大臣賞を受賞しました
の時本当に嬉しかったです自分のアイディア1人で行動して私にとってこのアイディア
などが社会的に認められたこと本当に嬉しかったです
でも私はこの日本一を取ったことよりもっと嬉しい事が
あったんです
それはとあるこのプレゼン終わった後に話しかけてくれた音大生との出会いです
彼女はこう言いました
私は
3日前
祖父を進呈してなくしました
この adi のプランを聞いて
もし
という方はれた時にこの adi があったら
私の祖父は救われたかもしれない
私は
ずっとおじいちゃんにかわいがってもらってていつも楽器などもおじいちゃんに買って
もらってすごくお世話になってた
でも私おじいちゃんにありがとうのお別れの挨拶もさよなでもいいやずに
おじいちゃんはもう帰らぬ人となった
もう会えないんです
だから私みたいにこんな悲しい思いをする人が
一人でも多く減るように私はしたい
だから
この adi のプランを実現させることを私は心から祈ってます
adi をあなたが実現させてください
そう彼女におっしゃってもらいました
今まで私はこのプランを発表してこのプランすごいねこの愛であったら本当に社会が
良くなるよねって言ってもらったことはたくさんありました
でも今まではなかったんですこのアイディアを本当に必要とする人
adi の実現を心から待ってくれている人
今まではいなかったんです
だからすごく嬉しかったです
でも私は同時にすっごく悔しかった
それは私は日本一を取って文部科学大臣賞を取ったとしても人の命は誰1人として救え
ていない
賞を取っても
人の命を救うという本当の意味では社会は変わらないんです
だから私はこの時決めました
私は人生をかけてこの adi を実現させる
だから今もずっと活動しています
そしてこの a 気愛はアイディアだけではなくて本当に命を救うために今まさに
活動が続けられています
実際私は5日前に和歌山県の有田市にでムキー
有田市長副市長教育委員長議長
様々な大人と2日かけて議論をしてついに実際
市内の中学校で営利愛の実証実験を行うことが決定しました
私はこの活動を続ける中で
あることに気付いたんです
それは自分の未来は自分で切り開くつ低いひらけること
冒頭にも述べましたが私はずっと幼い頃から医療従事者になることを目指していました
医者になって薬剤師になって人の命を救う
人の健康を守る
そうずっと思っていました
でも活動を続ける中で気付いたんです
医学を学んでいるだけでは100学を学んでいるだけでは本当の意味で社会が支えられ
ない
医療不可経営学デザイン心理
多くのことを学ばないと本当に社会に意味に価値あるものを提供できないんです
だから私は振動を変えました
私は今慶應義塾大学称号政策学部で様々な医療や経営のことを学んでいます
また私は
多くの企業や行政を巻き込みました
初めはずっと
や高校生の女子高生1人に対して
行政何か協力している協力してくれるわけない
どうせあしらわれるんや
そう思ってました
でも実際は違ったんです
行政は私の夢に対して全力で一緒に仲間となって協力してくれました
ずっと応援してくれました
だからわたしは
彼らに恩返しがしたい
でもそれはありがとうございました
の一言ではないんです
人と私はありがとうではなくて活動通して彼らに恩返しをしたいなと考えています
祖父の新弟子によって
私が振動を変えるきっかけとなった祖父や
また
私がこれを人生をかけてやろうと思えたあの音大生との出会い
そして私に一緒に夢を追いかけてくれようとした
行政の人たち
私は彼らに関し反射 c 感謝されそして初めて
私は自分の信念を本質を見失わずにつき進めることができました
そしてその暁には私は自分に未来を切り開けると信じています
祖父の新弟子を無駄にはしたくない
えーるはずの命を
一人でも多く
救う
私はそのためにこれからも活動していこうと思っています
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]